y meta antes conocida como facebook la
compañía tecnológica fundada por marck
zuckerberg anunció este lunes el
desmantelamiento de una granja de trolls
o cuentas falsas operada por el
ejecutivo nicaragüense en el comunicado
meta califica la red intergubernamental
como la más grande desmantelada por la
tecnológica hasta ahora estarían
implicados en la operación desde el
partido sandinista a la familia
presidencial pasando por el instituto de
telecomunicaciones hasta la corte
suprema
esta operación se dirigía a audiencias
locales y estaba vinculada al gobierno
de nicaragua y el partido frente
sandinista de liberación nacional
detectamos una parte de esta red a
través de una investigación interna
sobre el comportamiento in auténtico
coordinado en la región y el resto
tras revisar reportes públicos sobre
esta actividad
según la plataforma de zuckerberg la red
de mensajes falsos automatizados se puso
en marcha en 2018 para contrarrestar las
opiniones opositoras predominantes en
las redes sociales en el contexto de las
masivas manifestaciones
antigubernamentales
fuertemente reprimidas por las
autoridades la granja de bots estuvo
operativa hasta hace un mes con el
objetivo de favorecer la imagen de
ortega que busca su tercera reelección
consecutiva en las polémicas
presidenciales de este 7 de noviembre lo
que nosotros esperamos ahora es que todo
concluya en paz todo que concluya en
armonía y que cada quien pues qué
que bote donde donde quieran ellos
porque es en la elección la democracia
es o la revalidación del exguerrillero
está prácticamente asegurada dado que
los principales precandidatos opositores
han sido encarcelados y la mayoría de
los medios de comunicación son
administrados por su círculo cercano
dejando a un lado la política
nicaragüense en medio del debate sobre
el poder de hacker berg el comunicado de
facebook también abre la cuestión sobre
el rol que le damos a esta plataforma en
el arbitraje del espacio virtual